my feelings on a Donald Trump not a fan
and I think that's putting it delicately
my loyalty is to the founding documents
and to any other party affiliation or
candidate my blue up with you them
extend is that exactly as far as their
loyalty to the founding documents of our
nation I definitely don't support Donald
Trump for president they very much see
by and large here in Utah during this
election cycle that Donald Trump is
antithetical to their views he doesn't
seem to be a person of character doesn't
seem to really have integrity I think
that's a lot of we place a lot of value
on that here in a region
if you look at what Donald Trump has
said about Muslims for example I think a
lot of mormons remember our own history
of religious persecution and having
completely innocent people run out of
their homes assassinated by mobs which
included government actors the
particular history of the LDS culture of
being pushed out I think that memory is
still there the willingness to throw
entire cultures under the bus there's a
legitimate fear for how groups will be
treated when somebody you know comes to
power and is willing to wield it I think
Mormons tend to lean libertarian because
as part of our doctrine we believe that
this earth life is for the purpose of
learning and in order to learn and
progress mapped ad agency that is a
deep-seated belief amongst LDS people is
not just the right feel of our lives the
way we feel best about but to allow
everybody else to live their lives the
way they feel best about as well even if
it's not in alignment with our own
beliefs our founding Prophet Joseph
Smith has a great quote where he says
that you want to teach people correct
principles and let them govern
themselves that's a very laissez-faire
approach to governance
Hillary Clinton I am also not a fan she
is about as corrupt as they come I will
be supporting Gary Johnson I'm
definitely seriously looking at Gary
Johnson although he's a little bit more
liberal than libertarian in some ways
currently I plan to vote for Darrell
castle he seems to be the only candidate
that really supports the founding
documents supports the Constitution when
it comes to Gary Johnson who claims to
be for religious liberty and to support
religious liberty my problem with that
is when asked about for example should
bakeries be forced to make wedding cakes
for gay weddings he believes they should
be forced to I think you've got a lot of
mostly Mormon conservatives in Utah who
are scrambling trying to find who
they're going to support although Gary I
think has missed a lot of opportunities
by attacking religious freedom I think
that's why you see Gary Johnson gaining
so much support in utah's because of the
vacuum that's been created by the Trump
campaign among these very highly
religious people for whom morality is
very important both as a personal virtue
and as an outward public policy as well